the decision to pardon homer plessy he's
a man at the center of the landmark
supreme court case plessy versus
ferguson plessy a black man was arrested
and convicted for refusing to leave an
all-white rail car this was back in
1892. now his case led to the supreme
court ruling that upheld separate but
equal laws allowing racial segregation
to continue legally in our country for
more than six decades so on wednesday
louisiana's governor signed his pardon
posthumously near the place plessy was
arrested almost 130 years ago plus he
never had the chance to see
desegregation in america because he died
in 1925. our lead national correspondent
that's david bagnow has been in new
orleans all week one of his favorite
places speaking with the descendants of
plessy and the only supreme court
justice to rule against segregation in
1896.
david this is quite a story good morning
to you
good morning gail i don't think i've
ever been live inside of a courtroom a
criminal court on television but here we
go welcome to section a of the criminal
court here in orleans parish louisiana
we are here because section a is where
homer plessy stood 125 years ago and
pleaded guilty he paid a fine and he
lived the rest of his life as a
convicted criminal what was his crime
you're probably asking
essentially it was being black
on a white train car
only a marker stands where homer plessy
a black man was arrested in 1892 in new
orleans for sitting in the white section
of a louisiana train car
[Music]
130 years later people gathered there to
witness the wrong being made right by
louisiana's governor john bel edwards
while this pardon has been a long time
coming
we can all acknowledge this is a day
that should have never had to happen
in the landmark plessy versus ferguson
u.s supreme court case of 1896
seven of the eight justices ruled in a
damning decision that upheld
passengers on trains could be separated
by race plessy versus ferguson didn't
start segregation plessy versus ferguson
only gave it the blessing of law angela
bell teaches law at southern university
plessy gives us the groundwork for this
doctrine of separate but equal that
unfortunately does not just remain in
the railcars it now spills over into the
jury box it spills over into schools
theaters public accommodations after
plessy versus ferguson is that when
louisiana implemented this non-unanimous
jury system that you could convict
someone of murder even though not
everyone on the jury agreed it was a
direct result of plessy
this week dignitaries and descendants of
those who supported and opposed homer
plessy
came to this historic site
keith blessing first cousin three
generations removed from home of plessy
phoebe ferguson is the great great
granddaughter of the segregationist
judge john howard ferguson who convicted
plessy it is this unjust
criminal conviction that has brought us
here today
and cellist kate dillingham
her great-great-grandfather john harlan
a one-time kentucky slaveholder
who became a us supreme court justice
was the lone vote against segregation
and in support of homer plessy and he
wrote a dissent in 1896 remind everybody
what he said the constitution is
colorblind
and and you can't have states like
louisiana
that would solely on the basis of color
and race deprive people of their civil
liberties over the holidays governor
edwards read more about the history
behind plessy versus ferguson as he
prepared to pardon him pleasure to meet
you it's a pleasure to meet you okay the
descendants are doing it in their own
way a little emotional for me i think
likewise so when the three of them met
oh it's so great to meet you there was a
lot to talk about
descendants unite phoebe ferguson and
keith plessy have known each other for
years when i first met
keith
you know just you know the reality of
ferguson
meeting plessy
i got some apologizing to do here
[Music]
yeah i get it and when he said to you
but but don't apologize let's move
forward together what was the way he
said it they established a foundation
plessy and ferguson to educate and
remind people about the impacts of
plessy versus ferguson your thoughts as
you said in this moment it's deeply
moving
very emotional for me and my family i'm
representing a large
number of harlan descendants this is a
quote from justice harlem the arbitrary
separation of citizens on the basis of
race while they are on a public highway
is a badge of servitude wholly
inconsistent with the civil freedom and
equality before the law established by
the constitution it cannot
be justified
upon any legal grounds keith i saw you
smiling and shaking and what's going
through your head ah yes those words are
magic
to the legal
community
um there's not a lawyer that you could
talk to that's not familiar with those
words and for uk i feel like they're
etched in stone those words you know in
in
my consciousness
kate took her great-great-grandfather's
words and amplified them with her cello
playing lift every voice and sing at
this week's ceremony the lift every
voice and seeing is the
african-american national anthem it is
the song that kept people going
it gave governor edwards a battle cry do
hereby grant a full posthumous pardon
for the above list of defenses
to homer a plessy person homer adolf
plessy is now the first person in
louisiana to be pardoned posthumously
130 years after he stood up for the
right to sit down in the whites only
section of a train he is no longer a
convicted criminal we can breathe now
[Music]
let's end with a surprise i started by
telling you that i'm in section a of the
criminal court here in orleans parish
section a is where homer plessy appeared
and pleaded guilty well about two days
ago i got a call from judge lori white
who was the presiding judge here and she
said david
i intend to name my courtroom for home
or plessy think about this for a minute
the man who came here and pleaded guilty
because of the color of his skin
is about to have this courtroom named
for him the homer plessy
courtroom
yeah we just saw a nice wide shot of the
courtroom too thank you chante for the
shot you know david you number one you
give the best surprises let me just say
that yeah number two it's what your mom
always says it's never too late to do
the right thing such as touching
such a touching story between all three
of them and how all three of them are
connected and david we also have to keep
it you know professor bell said
yeah please go right
well this is decades decades before rosa
parks right
so
homer plessy that that's right
60 yeah
go right ahead
60 years before rosa parks to your point
yes
what were you going to say professor
bell you started saying something about
professor bell
she said no matter how long how
agonizing the march toward justice is
justice always prevails
we could we we need a reminder of that
these days by the way mr big now for
many different things thank you thank
you so much david begg no he doesn't
miss at all he doesn't well done david
well done david